everyone in Orlando and we're all in it
go ahead okay like a poker deck yes like
exactly like a poker were you trying to
say pokey deck were you was I know you
know your life is different now I'm here
with maybe heart and heart
we've made videos on their channels that
you guys should go check out but watch
this video first and went on Twitter and
asked everyone what kind of video we
should make today and a lot of people
wanted us to react to either old videos
or old photos or old tweets and so I
went on your Instagram and I found some
of your first instagrams that you guys
have ever uploaded Oh No
and we're gonna react to all of them
together right public information you
posted this voluntarily oops I learned a
lot I learned a lot about you guys in
the last bit what could you possibly
learn that you don't already know okay
we're gonna separate memory these are in
a specific order these are just from the
first few weeks we started using inside
223 weeks ago can you tell us what's
happening here I live in Pittsburgh
visiting someone over the holidays and
we go see the hub in 3d like some weird
transitional lenses on JetBlue
I think you actually pretty amazing I
thought you're in the middle of a sketch
comedy show and that you are doing it
Pittsburgh gets very cold over the
holidays and you know when temperatures
reach such a low you just can't give any
such now and this to me looks like
recently divorced aunt I just discovered
I like George Excel I like that it's
exactly what the caption says yeah I'm
either about to see on the 3d in
Pittsburgh or my new look is old wreck
buh buh ray says it's both okay here's
another Randy Hart photo from 1:30
Wow
am I not your morning person you guys
with a Z look at me if you are honestly
not much has changed baby could posted
this yesterday I have no idea where I am
though is what you say every morning
when you wake up though it is a timeless
7-eleven cup you guys you know how into
7-eleven coffee are you enjoy how many
varieties they have every morning yes
yes you actually have become more of a
morning person so that's true
so you hundred thirty weeks later who's
a wanna bet the end Bethenny and she
just says are so great do you know her
no you don't have to know me to know my
greatness
this our very first Instagram photo Wow
we berries make my uterus ache it's my
first Instagram account
a lot of people like to go in and be
like this is my first insta etcetera I
just like to go in there like I've
always done it no you don't know there's
these things called Kiwi berries they're
low berries and you slice them open and
they look like tiny Kiwis I like that
one of the first comments from chow
Santa's is that'll sting thank you hey I
was encouraged by my interesting content
to continue posting and here we are 260
three weeks later in know my angles yet
again the photo of your most recent
Instagram just a completely where you've
come from okay now let's move on to
Hannah Hart beginning of Hannah Hart and
Jazzercise is full okay what's happening
with your hair why are you I don't know
what's happening with my hair for like
five years
I you know I came into this flip phone
prom off something it just became my
favorite like I would pretend to talk on
it just on the street just to get look
like someone loves the rise filter oh
you guys remember when you would do
Hipstamatic or whatever you go around
the onions for the day a lot of
intentional choices are made this photo
this guy loves life says damn just damn
I left so hard at that Shh you've done
it again you magnificent sure
gonna move on to okay 261 weeks ago I'm
getting to suspect that my hair has a
very active nightlife this is when you
want a party girl yeah look at that no I
know this photo was taken when I first
moved to LA after I first started having
Instagram and this is my hair would look
like in the morning before I started
shaving chunks out of it till when I
wake up in the morning it still kind of
looks it's kind of crazy I wish I had a
photo of us in the van the other day
when you refused to pressure hair
because you thought it's gonna fall out
the shampoo on dress her stairs
dreadlocks coming straight out the back
of her stuff you know what's so funny I
remember when I posted this photo I was
like I'm starting to look a little older
well a cousin a tour boy band wanna be
like time for a haircut is really short
in that photo but yeah I think I needed
a haircut you're very like Bieber s very
Bieber this is before you started dyeing
your hair it is forgot what it looked
like yeah that's my natural colors I'm
like gluten free Satan says damn Nick
Carr to be looking fine these days is
this still one like you couldn't use
like flash on forward-facing you're
gonna take pics of my drunk kitchen I
guess oh yeah are you getting smoked
meats yep are those pop-tarts with meat
and I actually don't know why I hash tag
pop-tarts because that's confusing to us
both this MDK is a beer but chicken and
that's the chicken there broke your bark
tarts involved I love your art direction
of the huge stack of cup I'm pretty sure
my older sister Naomi just took this
photo I believe that I was too drunk to
make choices looks like this is mocha
linear and the cups are you
reckless whatever eclipses know you this
is your doing your career I know I love
it oh my God look right at you baby gosh
really I don't know really why I started
driving and before I started laser hair
removal as you can see that I find fun I
still have that fun oh it's hard to look
right maybe ray Jackson here yeah am wow
this is crazy I mean when you travel
together it's always good to check
moments to reflect that's why I thought
this might be appropriate you want to
speak to the manager okay over 30,000
Ray's this my happy thing
hashtag showered hashtag hello hard yeah
the day I launched the campaign and we
had raised $30,000 already I guess at
this point we met our goal of 50,000
thereafter and that's a lot of hair I
understand cap this for myself to be
like oh yeah Hannah did have this hair
before Shannon and your length hey I did
I did your leg hair but what's like yeah
and that was my natural color I think
you look fresh oh I put on mascara for
that photo I was gonna say I start
experimenting with makeup and walk into
the room like she was a cartoon flirting
keep it like hello to triangles all
right three TV okay we have to go ride
ATVs here in Iceland in a second but
really quick I didn't want you guys to
feel like we were judging you guys
without judging me so this is how we
going first Instagram photo which I
didn't know what was the public thing I
thought it was just a camera roll
because my first like 10 photos are at a
baby shower of just candy
yes you look like a beautiful horse in
the wind thank you so very harsh really
are cancel Jazzercise thank you guys for
participating in this and it's always
fun when you're with friends to look
back on where you started and now with
that we're going to go right at ApS in
Iceland make sure you guys put your cup
maybe shine on Hannah's channel we shot
videos over there that we're disgusting
and wonderful than that I don't know
yeah the first night that the three of
us hung out and shot videos in my
apartment in Brooklyn and I Geass
and you puked caption this it's like a
horizontal mullick so that's what mamrie
set your hair was like that's right
you're so scared of me that day that day
wasn't it the first day you had shaved
that was oh yeah there's a lot of new
things happening I was going to be next
to the first time and I had infused
tequila with passion fruit tea and it
didn't taste like a tequila I have a
drunk kitchen just sipping vodka out of
the bottle I believe I spent the night
and I lived three blocks away yes